[Musik]
heute ist auch zu sehen was ist mit dir
los schiesst euro das muss eigentlich
[Musik]
etwas glaubt und herzlich willkommen
beim ein video leute gar nicht drumherum
reden wir haben gerade mich rein uhr
wir haben mit zwei uhr wir haben auch
nicht drei uhr aber wir haben fast bei
uhr wir haben zwei 51 und was auf ihren
teil zum flüstern weil die meisten
menschen schlafen um diese uhrzeit außer
ich weiß auch nicht warum aber ich
fliege morgen nach berlin
und das hat gar nichts damit zu tun auf
jeden fall habe ich wirklich sehr viel
davon mitbekommen
von diesen drei uhr nachts videos und
ich find die videos einfach eine
bombastisch geil das sind zurzeit für
mich auf jeden fall die meisten videos
auf ganz youtube und deswegen muss ich
das auch einfach mal probieren leute
wichtig was für mich zu den feldwegen
gefeiert gleich mal los nicht zum
verkauf
damit sich auch mal wieder hin aber
gefahr nicht gleich los und bestellen
macdonald einen cheeseburger aber nicht
um ein uhr konnten 41 52 und 59 52 und
59 und 51 sekunden nein
um 3 uhr ich bin gespannt was passiert
keine ahnung
wir werden es sehen das gute ist der weg
ist ja ziemlich stunden auch und ein arm
steht gleich ab weil ich die kamera
schon so lange heißt deswegen will ganz
lange lagen wir
sorry leute ganz ganz ganz ganz kurze
werbeunterbrechungen ich wollte noch
einmal schnell sagen ich bin diesem
samstag an sketchen in berlin
ich bin diesem samstag am aspen sitten
auf der you messe in berlin kommt auf
jeden fall vorbei ich werde vom zdf
bleibt deswegen wir mega cool also wenn
ihr aus der umgebung kommt kommt rum
infos dazu in der video beschreibung und
ich sage am ende das auch noch mal
ausführlich aus als am ende von diesem
video
heute sind die flocken das hat auch
keinen fall was gutes zu bedeuten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
richmond auf den straßen jetzt wirklich
nicht so wirklich schon so spät ich
glaube die leute haben wirklich angst
vor dem neuen trend und geht dann ich
ausschlafen bis gar nicht mitzubekommen
ich muss mich auch ein bisschen weil ich
habe noch fünf minuten
also wir sehen uns gleich
19 räte dass schon das mcdonald
einleuchten
ich glaube das ist ein gutes zeichen
alter cassia mache ich nun meine haare
[Musik]
dieser moment wird
foto
wiesberger betreiber das st
brüssel
birkenstock
scheiße mann schon jetzt runter gefallen
[Musik]
okay leute
wir haben mittlerweile nach 3 uhr aber
ich habe die bestellung ja genau um 3
uhr aufgegeben
deswegen bin ich jetzt einfach mal
gespannt was da drin ist
ich würde sagen ich hab mir gerade im
auto überlegt ein die das video
innerhalb von 24 stunden seien 12.000
leicht bekommt dann macht das ganze auch
in dem ich um drei uhr nachts pizza
bestellen und die zu mir nach hause
liefern lassen
das muss man sich auf jeden fall mal so
auf der zunge zergehen lassen ich habe
übrigens meinen strom verloren wie das
runter gefallen hat sich das
entgegengenommen habe das ist das
schlimmste sein max bächer zu haben oder
sturheit
also schafft ihr seid bereit ich muss
erst mal kurz das runterkommen vor ein
schlupfwinkel von meiner frank schaefer
[Musik]
komisches milligan stattfand also also
sieht als die handtasche mitgehen wie
ganz anders ok jetzt machen wir das
ganze mal auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kommunen mittel
[Musik]
ja
alles voller blut
auf jeden fall gut okay leute also in
der box ist ein spiel zurück mario gomez
der cheeseburger und blut ich mache
jetzt einfach mal aus ich musste die
ganze zeit auf die kamera gucken um zu
sehen ob dieses bewegt
[Musik]
das ravensburger weiter
pflaster eingelassen hätte sie auch
gedacht dass das so passiert also dafür
ist auf jeden fall schon einen dritten
daumen nach oben
ok ich mag the box ist einfach mal zu
und ich lasse sie mit mir haben ist mir
irgendwie ein bisschen alter das geht
los
habt ihr auch grün was essen die
luftschicht dollar
das muss eigentlich etwa mit dem
duisburger liegen meint ernst wir
brechen das garantiert ab und spart sich
und glauben was ihr wollt aber doch kein
fake die komische das einzige was noch
mal schnell
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich weiß gar nicht was ich dazu sagen
soll
ich fahre morgen nach berlin und ich
musste auf jeden fall noch ein video
drehen aus dem zug zu schneiden weil ich
morgen wirklich kreist um zug fahre weil
ich als zug war und nicht fliege und und
ich die zeit natürlich nutzen möchte
wollen sollten wieder kommen also
vertraut mir bestellt euch niemals um
drei uhr nachts ein tief bei mcdonald's
aufwendig sehr gut schmeckt aber ihr
seht ihr was passiert also freunde
glaubt mir bestellt euch niemals ein
cheeseburger um drei uhr morgens folgen
20 schlafengehen schon unheimlich
schüsse schweiz
ich hoffe ihre siedlung nicht zu ernst
einzelkarten
sorry leute ganz ganz ganz kurze
werbeunterbrechung ich wollte noch
einmal schnell sagen ich bin diesem
samstag im schnitt kassen in berlin
ich bin diesem samstag am aspen sitten
auf der you messe in berlin kommt auf
jeden fall vorbei ich werde vom zdf
bleibt deswegen wir mega cool also wenn
er aus der umgebung kommt kommt rum
infos dazu in der video beschreibung und
ich sage am ende das auch noch mal
ausführlich aus also eine von diesem
video so leute also das wieder vorbei
noch ein paar kurze im vorteil ich
wollte noch mal ausführlich sagen weil
jetzt ist egal und dann eine lineare
sagen gemacht dass nur damit dass videos
zehn minuten wird
ich habe selber gesehen das video ist
glaube ich so neun minuten 20 und jetzt
damit vielleicht in zehn minuten ob er
mich jetzt noch nicht das war nicht
extra jährlich nicht auch keine werbung
geschaltet alte schild und ich werde auf
diesem video auch keine dort mit werbung
zeit vielleicht einmal geritten auf
jeden fall nochmal für alle aus großraum
berlin
er kennt ja wahrscheinlich die beste
kommt auf jeden fall vorbei wird mega
mega cool und er das ganze geht gleich
um 10 uhr los und ich habe in berlin
wirklich noch niemand also natürlich
auch um auf der straße aber in berlin
gab es noch nie dem treffen durch
zugesagte wird kommt alle deswegen und
der installierung von mir die meisten
kommen wirklich aus berlin
also kommt vorbei ins bescheid wir den
euro und jetzt muss ich mich ganz mehr
falsch machen dass sich hochladen und
wenn nicht ab zu einer richtig coole
party und wir sehen uns zu